[Music]
so i want you to think back
on if you've received an email from a
political campaign
that read something like this
or this
or this
so this is what my inbox looked like
last week
and i'll come clean
having worked on a campaign i've sent
thousands of these emails
a belated apology if any of you watching
are from the state of new hampshire
now it may come as a surprise to hear
that emails
are a major part of how candidates reach
voters
however i'm sure it's no surprise to
hear that they're incredibly ineffective
click-through rates are abysmal
and studies have shown that excess
outreach actually reduces intent to vote
it's counterproductive
however on a campaign
there's no time to experiment
no time to consider new strategies
we do what's been done before
in fact
over the last two decades
the playbook for driving voter turnout
has not significantly changed
we've just gone from door knocking
to bot worthy digital spam
and yet those of us working on campaigns
are baffled
given the billions
spent on elections every four years
how do we not have a better system for
voter outreach
or even more broadly
why does it seem that the issues
plaguing our democracy
are unending
the lack of secure voting
disinformation
partisan districting
i could go on
so this is what i'm here to talk about
today
one
what's wrong with our democracy
two
why democracy entrepreneurship might be
the solution
and three
how we can fund and support this work
so let's start with the first question
what's wrong with our democracy
you know most americans once
acknowledged a few universal truths
sun will rise
tom brady will win another super bowl
and american democracy will persist
now fast forward to 2022
tom brady is retired
and according to a recent poll
64 percent of americans
believe that u.s democracy is in crisis
now this is a harrowing fact
our democracy is the system by which we
peacefully transition power
and hold leaders accountable
it is because of the resiliency of our
democracy that we have free and fair
markets
and why the us dollar
is the world's reserve currency
without a trusted government
we cannot fight corruption
advocate for human rights
or pursue justice
these are the promises that a healthy
democracy delivers
thus
it is baffling to think that we are not
only ignoring improvement
but we're actively moving backwards
the last time trust levels in the
american democratic process were this
low
was in the 1850s in the lead up to the
civil war
the non-partisan electoral integrity
project ranks the united states second
to last among liberal democracies
and 57 overall
in administering trusted and fair
elections we must completely reject the
notion that our democracy will magically
bumble into better times
it won't without active intervention
so
with the laundry list of issues in tow
you'd guess a country like the united
states so focused on relentless
improvement would throw its full weight
into revitalizing democracy
however government isn't incentivized to
tackle democracy reform
and i could think of a few reasons why
one
it's hard to use the system
to change the system
politicians aren't incentivized to upend
the process that put them in power
two dependency corruption
the constant need to fundraise for
elections
often drives partisanship over progress
three
polarization
entrenched polarization makes any chance
at pipe at passing bipartisan electoral
reform
difficult
and four
the scale of government
even donors who are passionate about
democracy
think they can just support part reform
candidates
however
reform friendly politicians cannot
unilaterally make progress
so because government isn't incentivized
to tackle this issue
we need to do what america does best
turn to our entrepreneurs
in this case i'm talking about democracy
entrepreneurs
democracy entrepreneurs represent a
legion of passionate and patriotic
leaders
they include technologists
they include research organizations
they include community organizers
and they include advocacy groups
they drive innovation and change in a
space that needs it
it is because of democracy entrepreneurs
at ballot ready that we have access to
state and local level ballot information
with two clicks
it's because of democracy entrepreneurs
at rock the vote that we can register to
vote online
it's because of democracy entrepreneurs
at politifact that we have near instant
fact checking
of politicians
whereas private sector entrepreneurs
innovate in antiquated industries
and social entrepreneurs take on issues
tackling societal safety
democracy entrepreneurs
are working on solutions to build a
government of the people
by the people
and for the people
their key distinction is that they're
not chasing a financial exit
they're often non-profits or social
welfare organizations
so we've laid out the issues with
democracy
and identified who is best positioned to
fix them
so now to address the last question
how we can fund and support this work
to best illustrate this i'll share a
story about a time that i worked for a
democracy entrepreneur
at voterev we used behavioral science
and organizing expertise to drive
bipartisan voter turnout
it was september of 2020 and our
organization was unstoppable
we'd raised over 10 million dollars
we'd recently doubled our head count
and we were actively turning out
thousands of early voters
now fast forward to february 2021
exactly one month after the georgia
runoffs
we were no longer receiving
contributions
and over 50 percent of my colleagues
have been laid off
now the core issue
is that infusions of political dollars
are painfully tied to elections
every four years candidates and
political groups are flooded with
billions and like clockwork
post-elections
those dollars dry up
no matter how successful we were in 2020
we couldn't raise our series b
we had to downsize just like hundreds of
other democracy ventures
and just like that
progress was ground to a halt
and our democracy remained stuck
waiting for the inevitable
another election
for those funds to come flooding back in
so this is the fate of democracy
entrepreneurship today
blessed and damned by the whims of
donors
tied to the shoestrings of political
contributions
and wholly dependent on the cyclicality
of our elections
so
how do we fix this
the first part of the solution
involves reallocating political dollars
to fund democracy entrepreneurs
every four years donors give over 10
billion dollars to campaigns and
political groups
and only a fraction of a percent of that
money goes towards strengthening
democracy
just like we do with science and
infrastructure we need to make more
investments in democracy and we need to
make them more strategically and longer
term the second part of the solution
involves supporting this work
this is where you all come in
as future investors and operators we
need to empower this work by building
accelerators and incubators
by cementing democracy innovation as a
part of corporate social responsibility
by providing technical resources to
founders
and by evangelizing to build the
movement
i am calling for a pro-mass democracy
mobilization event
it's about time we recognize the service
of democracy entrepreneurs and flood
them with funding and support
we do this with the goal of inviting all
americans to co-create our nation
by giving them a fair say in the forces
that govern their lives
and i'll end with this
it's not about which side wins
what matters most
is for american democracy to win
[Music]